time for some nads gasps neighs gasps no
all right schemes good I look goddamn
fabulous I look amazing
do you oh yeah we have the same outfit
why are you look at me look at my well
same outfit I got that lien oh Jesus you
guys will pick the same skin they say
that I actually pick that skin as well
change outfit one stops it's my outfit I
don't mean to alarm you but there are
vampires
oh god this vampires ah he's dead he's
dead now you're dead oh my god I just
got destroyed like god this is terrible
I even see what kills me that I'm dead
sorry uh Minnie I thought there was
another one in there with us and that's
why I thought it was you
Oh weapons but bill oh my god oh my gosh
come on I think you keep doing stuff
telling us we're having fun we're having
fun everyone's Wunderland participation
medals for everyone baby on hat yes we
go Kevin
hey hey 410 they keep something yes okay
thank you God blue man I'm slore ok I
whip that ass
Oh so swimming you into [ __ ] [ __ ]
all gone minute legs up oh thanks foot
I'm dead guys I'm all alone
oh damn it where are you guys I'm
inviting me how my gosh hey Felix
where's the house station I didn't else
wipe out as well I need how stupid we
rescue rittany Felix don't worry oh
thanks hey guys wait oh no no God mini
sad oh oh you live out your debt you're
so dead no I'm alive I'm alive
Hey Oh minion run another web browser
shed get out oh nice I'm sorry dad as it
is save I never [ __ ] to see da one of
them with you what if that was you well
Felix just give them
hi guys everyone here I'm do I see that
sighs buddy there I was like oh hell
dumb
Oh excite Oh we go up Troy we're know we
can come back come on let's see can come
back oh [ __ ] no that's there's a real
eye blinded am i blind today am i blind
didn't kill him kill him kill him
oh no I'm saying we should get the doors
we should get indoors so he let Rose our
guys I'm up here now I don't what are
you doing sir Felix he spread me here
what am I supposed to help up guys Tom
Perkins rice Oh kills rip that [ __ ] Wow
with a good ever dies never dies get hot
don't you dare die with that [ __ ] oh my
god oh my god ah yo don't unsub me shut
up shorty and I would read remember how
we play the same pace minks it looks
like you're looking at my ass thank you
yeah it's right that hey almost checking
it out - uh-huh looking at my ass yeah
oh god cover me curl up in around you
feel killer again yo where the [ __ ] are
they they're all right oh yeah oh nice
weird million guys what's for eating gum
let me spank you get help back up above
you up above you there's a guy with a
shotgun nice
Gareth oh sure yeah why can't we do this
last time I don't know Oh surprise watch
and Damned whoa
fun nice yes yeah hey oh my god would
you hit eats literally you're gonna kill
me [ __ ] yeah while you're running at
[ __ ] nice feeling yeah I wish I was a
rich girl
[Music]
here we go come on two more kills guys
hey there's one more no more I finally
want to try the flying [ __ ] oh god I've
tried oh look at that glossy ass press
right click that works take whoa uh many
many many many waiting to me I want to
fly inside them no wait I like this game
Oh cuz he can he has balls and chins I
need help i need help he has balls and
chins yes Jesus this one using like a
supercharged up shot and it's just
wrecking me in LA
yeah yeah it's a sniper yeah I'm running
and lemme get him get him get it get it
get it
smack that [ __ ] ass it's nice and
super sit by the fire here Felix it's so
nice and warm
why don't we cut left making them I like
the decor guys we're losing oh okay oh
nice nice charge yeah he's so dead
yeah Wow ah oh my god nice where are
they get the other guy you get him get
him good I'm getting away
alright not this is the amount get here
Oh
oh my oh my got it oh yeah I'm gonna go
they mean let me appeal anybody
it's so close this guy this is quote Oh
we're even were even la la la la la Oh
God cool
[Applause]
it's okay guys we got this that makes me
sad
we're gonna try hard and I I'm crying
real tears oh my god feel like she looks
so nice
wow thanks but let me smack Oh birds I'm
bound huh incoming
ah I swear do you fix me up yeah it's
still here it's still here how do you
just I don't want to be the bait for
birds again put me down
we're getting destroyed here we are yeah
[Music]
oh god guys I'm so far from you don't
worry I got the bird ah you didn't get
[ __ ] didn't get you I know they chase to
me chase here we go I'm in first far
away so many [ __ ] birds there someone
wrapped up get him on it Oh - get me
down come on many one more this is bad I
make so die don't die don't die
oh [ __ ] I'm in here I'm in here alright
I am I guess my day huh help wrap him
I'll wrap him up charge Oh smack that
booty and it's bounces why do I keep
saying that I don't know oh okay I got
destroyed
oh that's he started sitting in the back
with a sniper it daddy
yeah the sniper is off to the side to
watch so fights like not anymore
I'm following him into the bang grave Oh
double kill [ __ ] follow me okay I
know here on the bridge Wow I didn't get
anyone Oh guys hey no Oh double charge
kill oh my god Jordan nice first I go
Dan alright let the big villains I'm
Joey and there's life is on the race
yeah yeah dinner time mm-hmm
I'm charging one edge he says go on I
got him don't worry yeah all right I
hope you liked that video we had a lot
of fun playing it if you want to check
out the game I'll leave a link to the
description and you can enjoy it
yourself but other than that I hope you
enjoyed this video thank you for
watching and leaving a like to become a
bike it's a lot of bikes watching my
video stay awesome bros
[Music]